okay so the verdict just came in and
officer Darren Wilson was not indicted
in the murder case of Michael Brown in
Ferguson Missouri obviously this is what
a lot of people have been fearing and
now we can only wonder what's gonna
happen over the next day's weeks
probably even months hopefully calmer
heads will prevail but the FBI has been
warning that violence is coming
the state of Missouri already declared a
state of emergency before the lack of
indictment click the link right down
below for more information on that and
we're gonna annotate right here you can
see some of our coverage that we've done
over the last couple weeks on this and I
just hope that kamar heads prevail there
are reasons that people want violence
there a reason that people want the
police to do too much but sometimes when
this terrible stuff is happening we can
try to be a little bit better as a
nation I think this is maybe one of
those moments so maybe we don't have to
go through hell to get there and
everyone can kind of calm down and see
what happens yeah that's it